hello I'm Elise and today I am going to  show you guys how I make one of my  favorite breakfasts this steak eggs  benedict I wake up pretty early I am a  super morning person shower skin care  all that and then I jump into making  breakfast right away I usually have eggs  in the morning always because eggs are  my favorite food I recently signed up  for this great free newsletter called  The Daily skim and it has made my  morning so much easier as a morning  person I give myself a lot of time just  to prepare myself mentally and  physically and I love doing that by  having a good breakfast and reading  through the daily skim now I'm going to  enjoy the most important meal of the day  while I catch up on what's going on in  the world with the daily skin it is so  easy to eat and scroll and then I'm  ready to start my day  [Music]  so tasty subscribe to the Daily skim now  seriously do it you'll thank me later